Politico Reporter Gabi or joins us for a
deeper look at these and other stories
Gabi good morning let's let's start with
this story that Michelle mentioned here
what if anything do we think the
Manhattan DA's office could be looking
at with regard to tamanna for right now
I think they're looking at heavily
redacted this case violating which is
why we haven't seen it yet made public
and the reason for that is there could
be significant indications in this
report about what direction they're
heading in whether or not Paul Manafort
is being charged with conspiracy we know
that he shared polling data during the
course of the 2016 Trump campaign with
Russian officials we know that he has
faced charges over his involvement in
Ukraine lobbying on behalf of Ukrainian
authorities and individuals there are so
many different aspects of this potential
case filing that could create
significant problems for Paul Manafort
and the other thing that we could be
looking for is whether or not there's
going to be any indication of how
cooperative he was with the special
counsel of course this is going to make
a sentencing recommendation and based on
that we might have some indication that
he was either very cooperative at the
beginning or not cooperative at all the
big question is when Muller's report
will land what are your sources telling
you you know there was some early
reporting last week that indicated that
might land this coming week we were told
yesterday by a senior DOJ official that
that's actually not going to be the case
but that it doesn't seem to be far off
so there is hope that this investigation
is going to wrap up in the future soon
at least but of course once it does that
could only you know indicate that that
House Democrats use whatever is in the
Moller report as sort of a roadmap to
continue their own oversight and their
own investigations and that could drag
on for four years as long as they
maintain control of the house and while
the president is not going to have to
deal with that Mullen report it appears
next week while he is at the second
summit with North Korea he may have to
deal with testimony from Michael Cohen
and you find that timing interesting it
is interesting and you know it's a huge
two huge events one happening
domestically the other happening on the
international level and the president
you know some of his advisors is sort of
worried going into the second summit
with Kim jong-un that he could make a
irrational decision he can make a broad
concession strictly because he wants to
distract
from whatever is happening on Capitol
Hill right and and you know with Michael
Cohen appearing before the the you know
House Democratic panel there are so many
things that we could learn when he does
testify just about his relationship with
Trump and of course we could potentially
see Democrats seized on something that
he says and then launch another
investigation into the president
meanwhile Democrats are moving have
moved to block the president's national
emergency declaration when this gets to
the floor for a vote are there likely
Republican defections here too in this
case
absolutely and that's a that's a huge
risk and it's one of the reasons why the
president was initially encouraged not
to pursue the path of invoking emergency
powers there are several Republicans who
have expressed concern about this not
only for ideological reasons but also
because they think that it really puts
Republicans in the danger of having a
precedent set that could backfire in the
future especially if a twenty twenty
Democrat takes control of the White
House and and it's not just in the house
where we could see this I mean Nancy
Pelosi is making a pretty politically
savvy move here putting Republicans on
the record against the president and if
this moves forward to the Senate there
are also several Republican men
Republican members people like Senator
Lee senator Rubio senator sass who all
could vote against this as well so the
2020 race just got a little bit wider
this week or any santur Sanders entered
what does he bring in this open field
well I think we saw that the energy is
still very much behind Bernie Sanders
when he announced his campaign in 24
hours 300 yeah which I mean in the first
three hours he blew past the fundraising
record that Kamala Harris had said when
her first 24 hours after announcing and
that sort of surprised a lot of people
there were people who thought that you
know Bernie Sanders yes he is lovably of
the most progressive but he's old news
he's much older than a lot of the other
candidates in the field and yet we see
that the momentum is still very much
behind him he has the name ID from last
time around
yeah if you're Joe Biden what do you
take from that I think that there's you
know on the one hand if you're Joe Biden
you're certainly a more moderate
candidate in the sense that he would
have appeal among some of those
working-class
blue-collar voters who supported
President Trump and yet you look at the
energy that's behind Joe are behind
Bernie Sanders and it might indicate
that maybe this isn't the right time to
jump into the feeling you feel the Bern
yes have you or thank you a wealth of
knowledge today on many topics